[Music]  the iconic franchise around the blue  hedgehog can't be kept down  paramount pictures announced his second  part shortly after the release of sonic  the hedgehog the popular character tales  already appeared in mid credit scene the  orange yellow fox and good friend of  sonic was all along in search of his  blue buddy who was hiding from his  enemies  first introduced in the video game in  1994 the short beat hedgehog who has  also become famous for the ugandan  knuckles mean  already became a fan favorite back then  due to his cool demeanor the skilled  climber could therefore also play a role  in the sequel alongside tales there's  already a favorite for the voiceover in  the film community namely none other  than dwayne johnson besides johnson  names like samuel jackson and chris rock  are also circulating as dubbing actors  for the animated characters  however nothing has been officially  confirmed yet a release can be expected  on april 8th  [Music]  2022  [Music]  bye